okay have you got some points yet Nevada
so what does it look like well you know
what x squared looks like right so
you've got you on you got your shape
like that now if you take just get some
values right and take the cube root of
each of these values right what kind of
behavior does it exhibit well it'll look
like this okay does that does that match
what you're looking at if you think
about it this way okay if you took
you've got x squared looks like this
okay
if you take the square root of x squared
the square root of x squared you
actually go to this you get to absolute
value okay but if you take the cube root
okay you're making it even shallow off
does that make sense if you took the
fourth root or maybe even shallow still
so that's why you've got this curve
actually happening what's going on again
there's a change in sign of the
derivative right you can see it negative
negative negative positive positive
positive now when I asked the question
what is the derivative at the origin
okay well I can um you can look at it
and say well it looks a bit weird but I
can you can do more than that you can
actually tell me what is the derivative
of the cube root of x squared we can
wait this out how do we do it okay now
let's rewrite this in index form to make
it a little easier for us because taking
a cube root is just X to the power third
right so if you have your index laws
like um X square is just two times up
there so keep that okay so now when we
find out derivative right this is just a
power right so that's going to be the
coefficient at the front and then you
reduce the power by one and now you can
see where the problem is crept in okay
because this negative sign is really
short for you know go on the denominator
right so this is two over three the cube
root of x so when you look at this
you're like well the derivative dy/dx is
not defined that's what I've written
here
the point the derivative is not defined
at the origin what's the derivative
there it doesn't have one okay and for
the same reason as we looked at before
as you take the limit of the derivative
from the bottom and from the top you
have completely different values okay so
therefore this is a lot of stationary
point but it is a turning point okay all
right
yeah so let's just review what a turning
point it's where you know the function
turns okay or the sign of the derivative
changes on either side okay number one
you can find stationary points that are
turning points and number two you can
find turning points that are stationary
points okay we should've drawn a better
then diagram the first time okay